you have the merch the energy drink the
podcast what is your next
big business endeavor bikinis
come on i'm gonna get into the playboy
business
but i do want to start with this new
business venture it's a new podcast it's
called
capital university and it's all about
money management
so i guess first of all why should we
listen to you
about money what if i just answered and
said because i have a lot of money now
i'm kidding
i'm probably one of the smarter people
with my money in this industry
um granted there are a lot of smart
people with their money but
when it comes to investments i feel like
i have definitely the best connections
out of all the influencers and it's the
podcast is a great way to learn about
investments and saving your money
and how important money actually is so
it's a good
concept what exactly inspired you
to want to share your story and to like
want to sort of
teach other people about finances and
money
i feel like it's a more learning
experience for influencers themselves i
feel like influencers should listen to
the podcast
and people who want to become
influencers or want to invest their
money
because it does give a good uh sense
of like yo you don't make money all the
time especially being in this industry
save it while you have it and invest it
what's the biggest lesson that you've
learned i learned that some months are
insane for money and then some months
they're just not
that's just how the influencer and life
goes
what do you do like when things aren't
as steady like do you give yourself a
budget
i just try to invest a certain amount of
money a year heck
i do a lot of tech investments what is
the the best thing that you feel like
you've
purchased over the past few months the
best thing i've purchased
probably my car is it a tesla do they
make that it's a tesla
it's a tesla that's not an appreciating
asset but
um i think the car was my
most um meaningful purchase because i
never had a car
i had a i had like a jeep back in
maryland but it wasn't mine it's my
mom's
and she just gave to me because she got
a new car so this is like my first
purchase
my first thing that i actually own yeah
it's a big deal you said that you at one
point went
completely broke when when was this and
how do you feel like that moment defined
how you sort of handle finances in 2018
when i say completely broke i meant like
five thousand dollars to my name
which isn't completely it which isn't
completely broke but it's like
not a very uh comfortable
not a very comfortable area to be in
especially in l.a
rent is expensive here so that was that
was like an eye-opener i was like holy
i don't make money i'm gonna have to
move back and go to college
get a real job and i don't want to do
that right now
do you feel like that sort of like lit
the fire underneath you to really
focus on all these different business
moves yeah i actually saw
like um some studies on athletes that's
where i really got like the original
idea of
wanting to get into this and shining
light to it i saw like
it was something around 70 something
percent of
all athletes after five years ago
completely broke
and in my opinion this is only my
opinion don't take my word on it but i
think social media influencers
everyone in this space we're just
athletes we're just another source of
entertainment
and in five years if you don't manage
your money correctly you will be broke i
guess that actually makes
a lot of sense unless you're like at a
different level like a david dobrik
level right
yeah and he he's smart with his
investments too he invests
he told me that he makes very little on
youtube
he actually revealed the amount that
like his checks are for
on youtube yeah mine are around the same
really
yeah so how how come you invest so much
into your youtube and how come you see
such a future in youtube if the payoff
isn't i don't care about the youtube
money
uh the youtube money isn't isn't where
i'm motivated
i just want to produce content that i
genuinely enjoy as long
as as long as my fans also enjoy it um i
rather put
really good content out and make no
money than putting out really
content sorry for my language content
and
making a bag off of something i don't
genuinely enjoy
let's go it's just me and this guitar
playing a
kind of walk me through the the
structure of this podcast
like if i tune in what am i gonna learn
are there different segments are you
gonna have other influencer guests first
thing you would learn would probably be
uh i'm not as stupid as i look
a second one is how much influencers and
everyone in our space make money like
how much they actually genuinely make
um three how to invest your money and
different areas of investments it's
almost like a classroom like a college
classroom
business 101 class it's it's almost
exactly modeled like that except we're
talking about some real capital
like real money like hundreds of
millions like
tens of millions like just real money
and we talk about like how
how we can turn that into that 10
million into 100 million
you said you're gonna reveal like how
much these influencers oh yeah
so what what is that figure well
most of the the audience thinks we make
over
10 mil or something like uh on a brand
deal but that's just not the case at all
i i know from being on the inside
and matching their analytics up to the
brand standpoint like
how much a brand would actually pay
based off of their numbers like i just
know
because i've been in this space for
seven years so
i i give a good i give a good outlook on
it you know
like i i know at least within 20 30
000 i know how much these kids are
making also being like friends with them
they tell me how much i make
so it's not upwards of i mean there's
all these lists that come out
some of those were cap
like cap as in like those were lies some
of those are lies
not accurate that's the difference net
worth and liquid are complete two
completely different things like
my net worth i think it says something
things i'm like
six mil seven mil i don't have seven mil
in my bank account i wish i did
but i don't so like you can't google
anyone's net worth none of this is like
public
to none of this is like accessible to
the public
you have the merch the energy drink the
podcast what is your next
big business endeavor bikinis
come on i'm gonna get into the playboy
business no you're not
yeah yeah explain that to me then i'm
kidding i'm kidding
that's just that's just an idea maybe
later down the road yeah
like do you want to start like a
playboy-esque empire
not even a playboy more like i would say
boutique
playboy's a little graphic boutique what
does that mean
boutique is like uh like a bikini line
and you would you would design the
bikinis or you would hire people to
design these
i would design bikinis why why we want
that we want the pa you want some
bikinis
why do you think you're the person to
design bikinis
is i'm the party animal
okay how do you feel like the like girls
are gonna feel about that
i feel like they'd love it okay and they
did buy it
the bikinis there is there's a good
that's a good market there's a lot of
money in it just because girls like
bikinis
yeah especially like girls be feeling
themselves now same with dudes
same with dudes but that's why i'm
coming out with my shorts party animal
shorts but
bikinis right now they're in dude
[Music]
tic toc has seemingly sold to oracle
how do you kind of feel about the
platform's
future and where do you see it going now
i still think tick tock's gonna get
banned i just don't know when
it's a matter of time but
i mean yeah there's it's just there's so
many different
times where it's where it's been
threatened to get banned it's just
inevitable at this point
you don't think that there's anything
that can prevent that and like how does
that even kind of make you feel
i don't know i mean i it makes me feel
like
i'm comfortable i don't i don't need
tick-tock
i don't need tick-tock anymore at this
point i'm doing it for fun
you